hi my name is Felix probably better
known as PewDiePie I'm making this video
just to say thank you in this instance
thank you it's nowhere near enough
basically thanks to my fans and some
other parties we raised four hundred and
fifty thousand dollars towards charity
water
what's up PewDiePie it's Kate from
charity water I just wanted to thank you
so much for fundraising for clean water
this year as of today at least 6500
people in Rwanda are getting access to
clean and safe drinking water for the
very first time thank you
it actually makes you the second largest
fundraiser of all time you good Justin
Bieber the original goal was $250,000
and we just killed it with 450,000 it's
incredible this has been an amazing
experience and I hope to do many more
charities in the future I'm so happy to
be able to do my use my YouTube
influence too for for something awesome
like this I want to thank Humble Bundle
I want to thank make her I want to thank
G to a games
I want to thank last night Starbreeze
studios donate an eleven thousand
dollars towards its charity
what else I feel like I'm forgetting
something oh yeah you bruh without you
brother
this would nowhere near be possible it's
all you I didn't do I don't want to take
any credits for something like this and
that's not what I did it anyway but this
is really something that you bros did
and something that together we made Anna
and I'm so happy happy to have such
awesome and supportive fans all I really
did was explain why you should donate
and you bros for all for this so thank
you so much for supporting this campaign
anything from just spreading the word to
actually donating a lot of money that
I've seen so many people donating
crazy amount towards his charity it's
it's been really hard for me reading all
the comments that you brothers have left
on that on the charity page saying all
kinds of nice things about this cause
thank you both so much you are really
the best and I'm just so proud and so
happy to have made a difference together
with you so thank you and for that I
wanted to do a breakfast so here you go
stay awesome bros this is amazing
say amazing from now on all right
you